sous sa piste d'athlétisme flambant neuf
se cache l'une des infrastructures les
plus imposantes de monde
[Musique]
il faut descendre bien plus bas pour le
comprendre de chaque côté de ce couloir
d'à peine un mètre de large il y a une
force colossale ici on est vraiment dans
l'antre du réseau heureusement derrière
chacun de ses murs cent dix mille mètres
cubes d'eau potable
cimade haut de chaque côté c'est toute
la dynamique de distribution c'est le
directeur du service de l'eau qui joue
le rôle de capitaine de ce navire la lui
au d'une passerelle il nous montre la
salle des machines cinq pompes qui vont
injecter l'eau dans le réseau c'est un
réservoir qui a été abandonné à la fin
des années soixante dix et qu'on remet
aujourd'hui même en fonctionnement cela
faisait quarante ans qu'il ne servait
plus et pour le réactiver il a fallu
repartir à zéro ou presque
reconstruire une toute nouvelle station
de pompage revoir l'étanchéité des
réservoirs
qui ressemble aux mines du royaume des
nains de tolkien
ça c'était avant de les inonder d'eau
potable cette eau qui dort maintenant en
attendant de couler au robinet en ajout
de 40% de la capacité donc c'est
gigantesque
faites le calcul on l'a fait et ça
représente 60 et une piscine olympique
cette nouvelle réserve n'était pas un
luxe malgré son coût de près de 200
millions de dollars des dépenses
engagées sous l'ère tremblay faut savoir
que personne peut se priver très
longtemps d'eau potable si de même à
pain lopata barrette en quelques heures
à peine les hôpitaux peuvent plus
fonctionner la mise en service de ce
réservoir ci va nous permettre également
d'entamer des travaux majeurs dans nos
infrastructures de l'eau natama la
station de pompage de réservoir
mactavish relier le réservoir
heureusement au réseau d'aqueduc a été
un défi parfois majeur il a fallu
creuser dans le rock avec un tunnelier
en diagonale à partir de la rue notre
dame pour faire passer une conduite sous
les résidences spas d'affaissement a
signalé le service de l'eau une
obsession la discrétion aujourd'hui on
se plaît à dire que notre objectif est
de passer inaperçu
car pendant la phase de mise en service
jusqu'en décembre et des agréments
pourraient survenir c'est pour ça que
certains citoyens aient de l'eau colorée
mais c'est sa respectable on surveillera
étroitement plan d'intervention
quand on dit certains citoyens c'est
tout de même jusqu'à 770 milles
personnes car ce réservoir alimentera
désormais une grande partie de l'est et
du sud de l'île de montréal la
discrétion c'est aussi et peut-être
surtout l'intégration au quartier
difficile de savoir qui lie à issy la
plus grande réserve d'eau potable
traiter du québec issime as-tu prost
radio-canada mourir